-Our first guest tonight
is an incredible actor
who produced and stars in
the new movie "Without Remorse."
It's available on
Amazon Prime Video tomorrow.
Here he is -- Michael B. Jordan!
That's what I'm talking about!
Yes!
Come on, bud!
It's always great to see you,
buddy. Welcome back to the show.
-Man, thanks for having me, man.
Thanks for having me.
How is everybody doing?
-Everyone's doing good.
We got a crowd.
We have people
back in the studio.
It's awesome.
-Love it. I love it.
-Pal, I want to ask you,
'cause the last time --
Since you've been on the show,
you were on the cover of a
magazine that was pretty epic.
Here it is right here.
The cover of "People."
You're the Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Now, I want to know --
I want to know,
how has your life changed since
being named Sexiest Man Alive?
-I mean, it's a gift
and a curse, you know?
People don't tell you that
you instantly have a target
on your back.
I mean, all my boys, you know,
in every group chat,
just imagine -- they're just
constantly roasting me.
And it's like everything I do,
it's,
"Oh, it's because
the Sexiest Man Alive
is taking off his jacket.
Oh, look at the way
he wears his shirt.
He eats like
the Sexiest Man Alive."
It's like, "All right.
Enough is enough."
But on the other hand,
my mom and, like, my aunts,
you know, they have it
kind of vacuum sealed.
You know what I mean? And, like,
you know, Saran-wrapped,
you know, that's, like,
up on the mantle.
-They bought every issue,
yeah, off the news stand.
-Every one.
Every one. Every one.
-That's awesome.
See, come on, bud.
Here you are on another cover
of a magazine.
This is the "Men's Health"
cover, which look at this.
Come on. That's...
-My boy Leo -- Leo Volcy --
did that cover.
He's my photographer
and videographer.
That was his first cover.
So it's special, it's special.
-Did he take this picture
on the inside of you --
This is you underwater
holding a rock.
-Yes. Yes,
he took that one, too.
It was a crazy workout, man.
I'm sitting up there, you know,
jumping up to the surface
trying to get some air,
dropping down there
trying to get the perfect --
the framing right.
-I'm sorry.
That's a workout?
You go down, you find a rock,
and you carry it?
-Yeah, well, a lot of surfers,
you know, and athletes,
they work on their breathing
and their conditioning,
you know, underwater.
So you would carry a stone that
would weight you to the bottom,
and you would just get
your cardio in underwater.
So, yeah, that was something
that we worked on.
-We have a similar workout.
[ Both laugh ]
-I'm sure, man.
-You're in pre-productive
for "Creed III."
I am psyched about this.
I can't wait.
I loved the first two.
But you're directing this one.
That's massive, buddy.
Congratulations.
-Yes.
-That's big.
-Thank you so much, man.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really excited about it,
you know?
It's the one character and story
that I know the most.
You know, third time doing it.
It's the third time
I've played any role before.
And I don't think you're ever
really ready to direct,
but, you know, you've just
got to jump in the deep end
and, you know, sink or swim.
-I want to talk about
your new movie.
But before that,
I just want to quickly mention
this cool thing you're doing
for your hometown,
for Newark.
-Yeah.
I'm putting on, you know,
HBCU Classic.
It's called
the Hoop Dreams Classic
that is taking place
in Newark, New Jersey,
at the Prudential Center
December 18th.
And I'm really excited about it,
man.
Honestly, just really
highlighting the HBCU's
and putting them on a stage
so they can be recognized,
their talent, and bringing
the community together.
I think it was important to do.
And I'm having a lot of fun,
man.
-I think it's important for you
to keep doing stuff like that.
I love that you keep doing stuff
like that.
Let's talk about your movie
"Without Remorse."
Now, this is Tom Clancy.
This is big shoes right here.
-Yes, sir.
-What made you
want to do this one?
-To be honest, as a kid, I used
to play "Rainbow Six" a lot.
Yeah!
-Wow!
-As a gamer, I used to play
the video game a lot,
and I've been a fan
of Tom Clancy
and his universe ever since.
So when I had the opportunity
to check out the script
and breathe some life into it
and basically modernize it,
make it more of a reflection of
the world that we live in today,
I kind of jumped
at the opportunity,
especially to do my own stunts.
You grow up watching
these types of movies.
You know what I mean?
You got Wesley Snipes
and Tom Cruise
and Michael Jai White
and Jackie Chan who trained,
you know what I'm saying,
for these stunts.
And now I get a chance
to do it myself?
I'm like, "Oh,
I'm all for that. Let me do it."
-I watch you do
all these stunts.
This really is
an action-packed movie.
Like, beyond
action-packed movie.
At one point, you're
fighting off three guys.
You light a car on fire.
And then you get in that car,
and I go,
"Never seen that one before.
Wow!"
And it's you doing it for real.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's me.
-Are you afraid? See, I would be
afraid of messing up the take
and be like, "Okay,
Jimmy, no big deal.
We'll just light another car
on fire."
-It's one of those things that
most of the stunts in the movie
you can train for.
You can't really train yourself
not to be hot.
You know what I'm saying?
The fire is the fire.
So that was probably
the one stunt
that I didn't think about
as much.
I just wanted to do it.
So they cover you
in this flame-retardant gel.
You know what I mean?
You might lose some eyebrows
and some eyelashes
in the process.
But I came away
with most of mine.
You just kind of hop in the --
you just hop in the car, man,
and you do the scene.
And, you know,
you got to get out.
It was hot. It was hot.
-Yeah.
Dude, this is fantastic.
And congrats on this one.
I want everyone to take a look
at this. Here's a clip.
Here's Michael B. Jordan
in "Without Remorse."
♪♪
-You remember me? Huh? Who was
the fourth guy in my house?
Give me a name.
-Aah!
-You give me a name.
Okay. I'll give you a name.
John Kelly.
You're problem.
You're supposed to be dead.
-Wow!
That's how you do it, buddy.
Michael B. Jordan, everybody.
"Without Remorse" is available
on Amazon Prime Video tomorrow.